NASA's plan to launch its most ambitious
moonshot in 50 years has been delayed
this is the giant SLS rocket at the
Kennedy Space Center in Florida this
morning it was supposed to launch today
but the plan was scrubbed because of
fuel leaks when it does launch this
Artemis 1 Mission will not include crew
NASA's goal is to land astronauts on the
moon in 2025 or 26. Mark straussman is
at the Kennedy Space Center for us this
morning as he has been for so many
milestones in space travel so Mark what
happened
well major disappointment John number
one uh four minutes before the launch
window was to open we got a message from
the launched director Mission scrub to
no go for today and the issue came up
during the fueling of the SLS rocket
that you're looking at right there and
and here's what happened so there are
four main engines in the core stage they
were loading the liquid oxygen and the
liquid hydrogen the the propellant that
drives the rocket to space the liquid
hydrogen was the issue for some reason
the they could not get the Liquid
hydrogen to properly chill one of the
four main engines and this went on for
several hours and again just as the
launch window was open was to open uh
they they called the mission apparently
because either they couldn't figure out
why the issue was popping up or they
needed more time to fix what was uh what
had come up but either way the decision
Vision simply was like we we just can't
pull us off today we've waited a half
century for an ambitious moonshot like
this if we have to wait a few more days
or a few more weeks depending how
significant this is then that's what
just what we're going to do
Mark tell me about the days and weeks
that period you just mentioned what
happens next during that period
well it kind of depends what goes on out
there John what the issue is what the
fix is
um the earliest let's say it's it's a
it's a it's a fairly simple fix a
relatively simple fix the earliest they
would launch again is this Friday they
have a two hour launch window that opens
uh at almost 1 pm eastern time on Friday
that's if that's best case scenario
worst case scenario they have to haul it
back into the garage the the Vehicle
Assembly Building and and fix what's
wrong and honestly depending how bad it
is I mean we could see a launch
weeks from now it could go on in late
later this month it could go on uh it
could run late in October I mean we just
don't know well all we know at this
point is that something has come up and
once again you know there have been
years of delay with uh with this rocket
um of production delays and and now
we're having a launch delay not nearly
as significant of course you want Safety
First and success second and for both
those reasons I think they said look
we're just gonna we're just gonna hold
off and wait until we're we're more
comfortable and confident that this
thing is working just as it ought to
all right Mark more details to come
thanks so much